Good morning.
All the title of today's lecture is the
Roman way of life and death at Ostia,
the port of Rome.
On Tuesday,
we spoke about architecture
under the emperor Hadrian,
the extraordinary Emperor Hadrian.
Uh,
we talked about the buildings that he
commissioned and some of which he also had
a hand in designing since,
as we mentioned, he was an
amateur architect himself.
Uh, we spoke about that Greek
import, the temple of Venus in Roma,
and also about the two major
commissions during his principles,
the Pantheon in Rome and
Hadrian's villa at Tivoli,
the main takeaway point,
visa vi both of these buildings and you
see them once again now on the screen at
left and right,
uh,
is that Hadrian followed the
lead of Trajan before him. Uh,
what Trajan had done and Apollo Doris
of Damascus had done in the forum of
Trajan and in the markets of Trajan.
And that is to combine in
one building complex, uh,
both the traditional and the innovative
strands of Roman architecture.
Uh, the traditional that goes back to
Greek and a trust can architecture and is
marked by the traditional elements that
traditional vocabulary of architecture,
namely columns and walls and
the roofs that they support.
And then more innovative
Roman architecture,
which is predicated on
concrete construction, uh,
faced with a variety of materials from
stone to what we'll see today is the
ascendance of brick, uh,
as a facing, which began,
as you'll recall after the fire
in [inaudible] 64 in Rome. Again,
looking at these two buildings
as examples of what Hadrian, uh,
he and his architects,
uh, tried to do, uh,
the Pantheon you'll recall on
the left has a traditional porch,
the porch that looks very much like a
typical Greek trust skin or Roman temple,
but then at a revolutionary body
when you walk inside the building,
a revolutionary,
a cylindrical drum and hemispherical dome.
And then with regard to the,
uh, Hadrian's villa at Tivoli,
I show you a view of the Chronopolis
and you'll recall that the CANopen makes
use of columnar architecture.
There are columns that border, uh,
one end of the pool,
although they are columns with a twist
because you can see they support a
straight and an RQ weighted lintel,
which we saw in second style Roman
wall painting in painting. Uh,
and then eventually it
begins to infiltrate.
Built architecture comes
to the fore under Hadrian.
So that's a playing around with those
lintels in a way you wouldn't have seen in
Greek and a trust can architecture,
but still realize in the main on the
traditional vocabulary of architecture.
But then you'll recall on the
other end of the pool, uh,
a building that was meant
to conjure up the, uh,
the Sarah p m in the temple of is in,
uh,
CANopen in Egypt, but that was made
out of concrete construction. Uh,
and that had a segment,
a dome,
a kind of Pumpkin dome that we
believe that Hadrian designed himself.
So this extraordinary combination
of traditional and innovative Roman
architecture that we see the hallmark
of Hadrian Anik architecture, uh,
and a gift that he gave to the
future evolution of architecture.
The other major contribution of the
Hadrian panic period that Hadrian himself
had less to do with because it was already
bubbling up after the fire and had 64
a is this is the move that we're going
to see today toward multistory housing.
We saw that begin already at the last
gasp of Pompeii and Herculaneum you'll
remember after the earthquake
of 62 and before the, uh,
the eruption of Vesuvius,
the Pompei ions and the those who
lived in Herculaneum began to build to,
began to add additional stories to
their residential structures usually.
And that meant for the most part,
a second story being added to
their residential structures,
but they never went beyond that.
What we see beginning to happen,
especially under Hadrian is the ae an
increased tastes for multistory buildings,
a multistory domiciles, but
multistory residences, uh,
that had more than two stories,
even up to as many as five stories
essentially apartment houses.
And our best example for such apartment
houses are in the city of Ostia,
the port city of Rome.
And it's therefore to the
city of Australia that we
are going to turn to today.
And in fact,
we will spend the entire lecture on the
city of Ostia because like Pompei and
Herculaneum before it, uh, especially
like palm pay, uh, we have,
uh,
an extraordinary array of not only
private domiciles but also public
architecture from the city of Osteo that
gives us an outstanding sense of what
the city looked like in antiquity.
I show you a plan of Ostia in its heyday.
You'll remember that the city was
actually founded very early on, uh,
at the very beginning of the semester.
We looked at the town plan of Ostia,
which data to the mid fourth century BC,
around 350 BC.
And you'll recall, and I'll remind
you of this plan in a moment. Uh,
you'll recall that it was founded as
it was actually Rome's first colony.
Uh, although it was a colony
in Italy, obviously night,
not outside the main land,
but it's first colony in Italy or
anywhere for that matter. Uh, and uh,
it was founded as so many of these
first colonies were as a military camp.
It was laid out as a costume,
as you'll recall.
And that costs from a one
can see in the very center.
I'm going to show you a better view of
this from Ward Perkins in a moment, uh,
but you can see that that
colonel, uh, of the, uh,
the costume plan or right here
in the center of this plan,
but what this plan shows you is the way
in which the city grew over time. Again,
it began in the republic. It continued
to be developed during the republic.
It was under Augustus
that some new buildings,
some public buildings were added to
the locale, uh, including the theater.
And we're going to look at the
theater today. Uh, and then, uh,
ports were added as you'll remember.
And I'll review that momentarily.
Ports were added at Portas,
uh,
by Claudius and also by Trajan. And, uh,
it was after the port of Trajan that the
city really began to take off in terms
of its commercial activity and much of
the building that we see in the city as
well as it looks still today,
a belongs to the Adriatic period and into
the time of the successors of Hadrian,
the so called and to nine
emperors whom will also be,
who's architecture will also be studying
this semester a while this plan is on
the screen. Let me just point
out the location of Rome.
The Arrow points this way.
The so called via osteon say the root
the street that leads from Rome to Ostia,
the via osteon say, and actually
the city road becomes the town,
the, uh, the, uh, country road.
The country thoroughfare becomes the
city street, the main city street,
the a deck humanness of the city of Ostia.
Uh,
you can also see in
this, in this plan, uh,
the location of a place called Easel,
a Socra up there,
which we will see was the
main cemetery for Osteo. Yes,
there are tombs outside the city walls,
uh,
also elsewhere in the city.
But our most best preserve tombs are
from this area called Easel a Sabra.
And I'll show that to you also today.
And here you can see the Tiber river,
the Tevere of the Tiber River
wending its way from Rome to osteon.
It is of course along the Tiber that we'll
see warehouses were located and where
the ships I went back and forth to export
or import material pro products from
Rome to Ostia. And back
again. We talked about again,
we talked about the
building of ports at Ostia.
We talked especially about the port,
the Claudius commissioned at Portas. Uh,
and I remind you of it on the
back of a neurone, one coin,
a coin of Nero adverse
with neuros portrait,
reverse representing that Claudia
and port. And we see it there.
You'll remember it had
curved break waters,
which you can see in that coin depiction,
uh, and uh, a river God at the bottom,
boats in the center as well
as the lighthouse. We see
all of that on the coin.
And you'll remember that the breakwaters
we're made up of columns that partook
of that rustication masonry,
that Claudius so favored down here.
I painting that I've shown you before,
that now is on,
that is on the walls
of the Vatican in Rome,
the Vatican museums in Rome where you
can see Claudia says port this cr,
it's curved breakwaters and
it's light house over here. Uh,
and then the port that was added by
Trajan during his reign, a multi-sided,
uh, additional port right
here. And it was again,
the construction of that particular port.
Uh,
that really brought commerce even
more. I mean, it had been used,
this area had been used since
the mid fourth century BC,
but it begins to really take off.
There's a real efflorescence
during this period. And, uh,
it is therefore not surprising
that with commerce booming,
there was more need for residential,
residential architecture
for those who live there,
for the traders and so on and so forth
who lived there. Uh, and we see this, um,
this,
uh,
the building of not only civic buildings
but especially of private domiciles
begins to move very rapidly.
A pace of the city becomes more crowded
and there becomes this need to build up
vertically as well as horizontally.
And we'll see that development today,
uh, tourists who go to Rome really missed
the boat by not going out to Ostia in
more,
in larger numbers because at most tourists
don't tend to take the trip out to
Ostia, but it's well worth it
and it's very easy to get to.
It only takes about 25 minutes to a half
an hour on a suburban train to get from
Rome to Ostia. So, uh, it's, it's
a not to be missed, uh, experience.
And I show you one of these trains in the
upper left that takes you very easily,
uh, from Rome to the site of Ostia. Uh,
there are a number of stations in Ostia.
One of them is Ostia change row,
the downtown of Ostia, which you
see in that view in the upper left.
And the other is Lido di Ostia,
which means the beach.
And I show you a view of
Lido di Ostia down here.
Now looking at that nice view of
the ocean. I know we've all been,
you're back from spring
break, but still it's, it's,
it's nice to reminisce about what some
of you may have been doing during spring
break and see this wonderful view of
the scene and it looks very enticing.
But I can tell you that it's not, once
you get there, I mean, it's very polluted.
This is not one of the great beaches
of the world. Uh, so don't be,
don't be seduced by Lido di Di Ostia.
Stay on the train and make your way to
the site called Scobie Diasio Ostia,
which is the excavations of Osteo,
the archeological excavations where you
can see as you saw as one season Pompei
and ancient Roman city, extremely
well preserved. Uh, and you see,
uh, a, a glimpse of it over here.
And you can tell even
just from this glimpse a,
that we are dealing here with a
city that is not unlike Pompei.
It has streets and sidewalks and it has
buildings along the side of either of
those. But there is one main difference
between this and what we saw at palm pay.
And you can see it very well in this
image and that is that these build, these,
these houses are that are along the street
look different than those did in palm
pay in that they are made out of concrete,
faced with brick,
a very different kind of appearance, uh,
and one that is quintessentially Osteon,
uh, and makes this city well
worthwhile, well worth a visit. In fact,
if we think of palm pay as
the quintessential first
century a d Roman city,
we should think of the city of Ostia
as the quintessential second century A.
Dot.
D City.
The best example that we have of what
a second century a Hadria Anik and
[inaudible] city would have looked like.
And that is what makes it
so important to us here.
I remind you again of the original plan
that we looked at the plan from the mid
fourth century BC,
350 BC from Ward Perkins.
That shows you the original
costume of the first colony, uh,
this rectangular space, very
regular with its own wall. Uh,
surrounding the city with the Carto,
these north South Street and the deck,
your Montas,
the east West Street intersecting
exactly at the center of that city.
And then at that intersection,
as was Roman practice,
the placement of the forum of the city,
a great open rectangular space with the
temple pushed up against the back wall
in this case at Temple of
Jupiter, a capital Eum, uh,
dominating the space in front of it.
And then other buildings around it.
As you can see,
although there's a striking difference
between this forum and the forum that we
saw at palm pay,
because you'll remember at palm pay,
the various major buildings, the
basilica, the temple of Apollo, and so on,
uh,
sort of radiating out from
the central core of the forum.
We don't see that here.
We see the buildings, uh,
sort of placed separately
from that main forum space,
but in every other respect,
very similar to the general plan
of these early Roman cities.
What's also useful about this particular
plan is the fact that it shows you the
way, though, as time went
by and as the city grew,
it shows you the way in which the carto
and the deck your Montas were extended.
And then the other buildings of the
city were added a here and there,
a number of baths,
lots of private residences.
This is a particularly important
building here at 15 and 16,
which we'll look at today.
The 15 is the theater and 16 is the so
called a Piatsa of the corporations,
the pee out solid daily corporates Yoni,
uh,
which is very significant
and we'll look at that soon.
If you go and visit the
city of Ostia today, uh,
and enter at the ticket booth.
Uh,
what you see almost immediately
is again, a polygonal, uh,
masonry, uh, street looking very
much like pom pay. But once again,
there are no stepping stones in Ostia
unlike Pompei, which is which a,
the plot thickens there in terms of why
we see those in Pompei and don't seem to
see them anywhere else.
You walk along that polygonal
Masonry Street pavement, uh,
and you see both the remains up here
in the upper left of the original
Republican city wall.
And it should bring back memories of opus
contract them or Ashleigh masonry that
we saw at the beginning of the semester.
You can see it's consistent with the age
in which it was built in the republic.
Uh, but then over here, as you
make your way along, one of them,
one of the main streets,
uh,
you see what is characteristic
of Ostia as a whole.
And that is concrete construction,
brick face, concrete construction,
both for the residences and also for
the public buildings and also for the
religious structures,
namely the temples, uh,
in this city. The reason
for this, of course,
it takes us back to the
neurone and period, the fact,
the great fire of 64 when it was realized,
you'll remember the Sabura,
uh, which was located back beyond the
precinct walls of the forum of Augustus.
The area where the working poor of
Rome lived primarily in Rickety, uh,
apartment houses that were made
out of wood, multistory to houses.
Those were actually multistory,
but they were always going up in flames.
And there was a recognition after the
great destruction of the fire of 64 that
the Romans needed to
fireproof their buildings.
And so they big and they recognize
the fact that brick is better at,
at protecting the structure
from fire than stone is a,
and they stoned Ken burn. Uh,
and they actually began to,
as we know we talked about this before,
they began to build their houses and
many of their civic structures out of
concrete faced, uh, with brick. Uh,
and we see that development especially
well here in Ostia and Osteo is extremely
important for us also because many of
many comparable buildings that were put up
in the city of Rome itself no longer
survive the same apartment houses that
we're going to see it. Ostia did exist
in Rome. We have some remains of them.
There's a very prominent one at the base
of the Capitol on hill to the left of
the hill as you,
as you climb up that hill.
But we have very little
evidence for this in Rome.
And so we have to rely on Ostia to
give us the best picture of apartment
building in Rome, in Roman
architecture in the second century.
A D here is a spectacular view of
Ostia as it looks today from the air.
And we are obviously looking down on
the forum on the great open rectangular
space as the forum with columns around it.
We are looking also at the Capitol,
Liam at the Temple of Jupiter,
which is a very large structure.
As you can see here.
It made out of concrete,
faced with brick.
It is a typical Roman temple,
unlike Hadrian's Temple of Venus in Roma,
because we can see that it has a facade
orientation. It has a single staircase,
it has a deep porch,
freestanding columns in that porch.
So a typical Roman, uh,
structure, uh, and uh,
and it's typical Roman temple.
And then you can also see its vast scale.
There are a couple of people standing
here who look minuscule in relationship to
this building. And, uh, only
part of the building. In fact,
full height of the building
is not even preserved here.
So it was even larger still
than what you see. Uh,
the reason for its size is two fold. One,
because we have already seen that this,
uh, this taste for larger and larger
buildings has really taken off.
Uh,
we saw it in Hadrian's forum in Rome.
We saw it in demolitions
palace on the Palatine Hill.
We saw it in Hadrian's villa at Tivoli
and in the Pantheon, the largest span,
the largest dome, uh, ever built.
So this taste for four largeness,
grandiosity and architecture
has really taken off.
So it's not surprising
to see this capital IOM,
which was built in the Adriatic periods,
specifically one 20 a d
also being large in scale,
but there's a second and perhaps
even more important reason.
And that is in a city in which all of the
most of the houses are what are called
Insoo lie,
I n s u l a and the singular
AIE in the plural into lie.
A multistory apartment buildings
often have as many as five stories.
If you want your capital,
Liam,
to stand out in that city and be
seen up above those apartment houses,
you've got to build it very high.
And that is undoubtedly the reason
that they are one of the two reasons,
the more important reason that they
have built this temple so large and
especially so tall so that you could see
the temple of Jupiter from everywhere
in the city of Ostia.
Here's the view of the temple as
it looks today in isolation, again,
only part of its hype preserved but
enough for us to get a very good sense of
it's concrete construction
brick facing here. Uh,
and as I've already described, the
single staircase, the columns, uh,
in the porch and so on.
I mentioned already that it
was under Augustus that uh,
a theater and an entertainment district
was added to the city of Ostia.
And, uh, it, it, that building,
you see the remains of it here a along
one of the major streets of the city of
Ostia.
It was renovated in around 200 a d
that is in the early part of the third
century,
a d.
So considerably later it was
expanded to be able to hold 200,
2,500 spectators at that particular point.
And uh,
much of the concrete and brick faced
construction belongs to that renovation.
One can't imagine a building quite
like this in the age of Augustus.
So what you're seeing here is
PR primarily the restored, uh,
view,
the restored version of this building.
But what you can see that does,
uh,
at least link it back to the Augusta and
period is the fact that the design of
the facade is very similar to the design
of the theater of Marcellus in Rome
with the art, with the arches and the,
in this case pilasters between them.
That same general scheme that we
saw for theater and for amphitheater
architecture use tier.
The main difference of course is the
fact that we have concrete construction
with brick facing,
uh,
rather than concrete construction
with stone facing travertine.
In the case of the theater of Marcellus,
I haven't yet shown you a Roman latrine,
but today is the day for the
Roman latrine. Uh, we and,
but you have to imagine of course,
that in any major public building like
a theater where you're going to have a
lot of people, they are the same time.
You have to provide a public latrine.
And when I say a public latrine,
I really mean a public lottery and there
was no privacy as you can see in this
latrine, a whatsoever.
Uh, what it, what it is,
what it is composed of as you can see
is a bench that lines the walls with a
series of holes in it. And then just
one single drain, uh, that in circles,
uh, the building. So this gives you
an idea of where you have to go.
If you needed to go, uh, during
intermission, if you were attending, uh,
the theater at the theater in Ostia,
one of the most important
buildings at osteon is, is, uh,
connected to this theater I'm showing
you now the plan of the theater,
which corresponds a two theaters that
we've looked at throughout this semester
of typical Roman plan.
It has a semicircular orchestra.
It has a stage building
or scan I frons here. Uh,
it has a semicircular Kavya the
street, they seats, which are,
um, which are, which are placed on
top of, of course, in this case,
a concrete foundation.
Uh,
this like other Roman Roman
theaters is an urban phenomenon.
There was no hill to build this on.
So the Romans had to build the osteons,
had to build their own hill
out of concrete and then
support the caveat on top
of that. But the coffee is made of stone
seats. They used stone for the seats,
as is traditional in Roman
theater architecture. Uh,
and then,
uh,
but we see that this theater
is appended to a portico us.
Now we've seen a porticas with these,
uh,
with these theaters before it was in
fact characteristic of theater design.
And if you think back to the
theater in palm pay, for example,
you'll remember that that port it goes,
which had a little cool little shops all
around it or small cubicles all around
it,
uh,
was used as a place where you could
go during intermission to relax,
to walk around,
to buy a playbill to pick up a souvenir
tee shirt or what the equivalent was in
those days,
uh,
a souvenir of your experience
that evening at the theater. Um,
and so we see that same
general scheme here,
this whole idea of this open
rectangular space with some columns. Uh,
and then with these little cubicles
all along. But in this case, uh,
it was not meant to be a place for
souvenirs or a place to store props,
but instead what we see is something
quite fascinating giving the,
given the fact that the city of Osteo
was primarily a commercial city,
a place where, uh, items were,
were exported and imported because
it was a major port or harbor city.
What this was used for instead,
uh, at hence its name, the P. Dot.
Salay daily corporates.
Yoni is a series of businesses that
were spent the import export business
essentially a is what these
spaces were used for. Uh,
and I'll show you, we, there are actually,
some of them are quite well preserved
and I can show you indeed what they look
like then in the center or something.
We also don't see in the palm pay
theater a small temple in the center,
a temple that corresponds to a Roman
temples that we've looked at thus far.
It's rectangular shape, uh, it's
flat side and back walls. Uh,
it's some columns in the deep porch,
a single staircase facade
emphasis as you can see here,
relatively small and scale
as these kinds of things go.
And it has been speculated by the
main excavator of this site that uh,
it was used as a it,
that it was dedicated to some
God whose name we don't know.
We don't know which God or
goddess this was dedicated to.
But the excavator has speculated that
it was probably some God that had
something to do with commerce.
And the blessing of commerce and
that probably some trade guild,
one of the trade guilds that
had its business is set up here,
may have been the commissioners may
have paid for indeed commission this
particular temple. And I
think that's uh, you know,
as good a theory is any
and may well be the case.
This is a view we're standing
at the top of the caveat.
Looking down over that coffee,
we can see the COO nay or wedge
shaped sections of, of seats.
We can see the stone stone that
has been used, uh, for those seats.
We can see the semicircular
orchestra, the scalloped, uh,
the scallop face of the,
uh,
of the or of the stage.
Uh,
and then one can imagine the skein I
frons with its forest of columns behind
that part is not well preserved.
Uh, and there also would have been,
I'll show you a restored view it a little
bit later where you'll see that there
was a much higher wall in
between this and the p. Dot.
Salie that lay beyond the
wall is no longer there.
So we can see very well
through these columns.
The small temple that was debt put
up by that trade guild to some God of
commerce.
And then we can also see these cubicles
all along the way that were used,
uh, as these import and
export, uh, Emporia.
This is a view of the temple as it looks
today. We can see that single staircase,
fairly narrow staircase here,
the facade orientation,
a couple of the columns including a
Corinthian column that are still preserved
from that small structure.
And then here are very useful
view showing us again, uh, these,
these interesting spaces,
rectangular spaces along here,
a fronted in each case by columns.
We'll see that those columns are made
out of cement, faced with bricks.
So it's shades of the sanctuary
of Hercules at Tivoli.
We haven't seen this before.
I've been since then and that
was a very unusual use here.
We're seeing something that actually
becomes more common in the second century,
uh, making concrete columns and
then facing them with brick.
I'd like to show you a few views
of these, uh, of these, uh,
of these import export businesses is,
I've called them, uh, one of them here.
Uh, where we can see that
the architecture itself,
the walls and the columns are
only partially preserved. Uh,
you have to imagine that an antiquity,
they went up higher than this. Uh,
but what is well preserved are
the mosaics on the floor, uh,
of each of these are many of these spaces.
And you can see they're all done in black
and white mosaic. Just the two colors.
You can see the interest
that the osteons had, uh,
in geometric shapes. Uh, they, uh,
have inside these very
abstract inside the shop here,
these abstract patterns. Uh,
although they, they've made
an attempt to vary them.
Uh, but then in the front, uh, something
very interesting that we see throughout,
uh,
is the use of see imagery because again,
they were in the import and export
business. They were busy, uh, you know,
sending ships,
uh,
back and forth for Middle East to other
parts of the Roman world by sea. Uh,
and so it's almost all see imagery here.
We see two Geraldo Dolphins.
Dolphins are particularly
popular in these scenes, uh,
facing one another as a kind
of advertisement or shops on a,
for this particular enterprise.
Here's another one,
a where you can see I like
this dolphin in particular,
he's nicely preserved and he has a
wonderful serpentine tail with a lot of
flourish at the end
here. As you can see, I,
and then inside a an image of a boat,
you can see it,
it's partially preserved.
What's wonderful about this example
is it shows us that although these are
fairly simple in design and
are meant essentially as
advertisements for the shop,
the artist and the patron have taken real
care to think about what you're going
to see when you're standing where so that
they have oriented these so that when
you're facing the shop and deciding
whether you're going to pick this one,
there's 61 of these by the way,
around the perimeter of the structure.
So you had a lot of choice in terms of
which enterprise you were going to. Uh,
you know,
you were where you were going to go to
if you wanted to ship something from
Ostia somewhere else or receive a
delivery, you had a lot of choices,
although I don't doubt
some of them specialize in
different parts of the world,
you know, and shipping to Egypt
or shipping to Asia Minor. Uh,
but you can see here the dolphin when
you standing deciding whether you want to
go in the dolphin,
you face the dolphin.
Once you're inside a and standing
and talking to the owner. If you,
if you turn around and look back
or you're going to see the ship,
the boat head on. So they've really,
they've orchestrated this and such.
They paid real attention.
It's not done willy nilly.
They paid attention to what
you're going to see where, uh,
when you are entering and
inside of these spaces.
Here's another one. Not only dolphins,
dolphins, dolphins, you know,
more dolphins and more dolphins.
Uh, but you also see in this case,
a light house which could either be a
representation of their local lighthouse
or some light house, uh, somewhere else,
uh, that this particular place ships too.
And then the last one, which is the one
on your monument list, uh, with two boats.
Uh, so again, how does one ship
things from a Ostia elsewhere by boat?
And so they tend to represent boats. And
you've see, you've kind of seen it all.
Dolphins, boats and light
houses tend to be, uh,
the items that are chosen for
these so called advertisements.
But this one is very useful too
because you can see the, uh,
the shapes and the colors of the
tests or I that are used here.
And although these are very effective,
you can see that this is
not the Alexander mosaic a,
these are not done with that
kind of skill. Uh, they,
they use only black and white, the
simplest possible scheme, no colors. Uh,
and you don't get the sense as you do
with something like the Alexander Mosaic.
When you step back from it,
it could almost be a painting.
It's done that well with the cast shadows
and the, and the crumpling figures.
So well presented, uh, here at something
quite different, more abstract. Uh,
and the stones are not as fine.
You can see they haven't
paid as much attention to
getting them perfectly shaped.
Uh, but nonetheless it's very
effective. Uh, and it really does.
It does what it intended to do.
One of the sad things, I mean,
it's great to see and if you go out to
osteon make a special point of seeing
these and taking pictures because I've
been looking at these for many years and
uh,
every time I'm there,
it seems that there are fewer tests
awry ride there then that these are the
originals are there are fewer tests
arrived than there were before.
I'm not saying that people take them,
although I think people do take them. Uh,
but, but just that over time by a, by
tourists walking on them extensively,
they get on,
they got,
they get loose and they get spread around
the site and they haven't done as good
a job as I think they should have at all
as they should at osteon keeping these
mosaics together.
Here's a restored view of the whole
complex where I think you can see that
although the theater and the [inaudible]
are connected to one another and are
part of the same scheme
and are a development,
a further development and evolution,
uh,
that is particularly appropriate for
this commercial city of Ostia that comes
out of the orbit of that earlier, uh, uh,
theater and porticas complex at Pompei,
we can see that although they're
part of that same complex,
they are distinct from one another.
Uh,
if you look at the theater and the copy
up above with the original wall of the
skein high frons preserve,
we're looking at it from the back or
you can see that that was very high. Uh,
so only if you were way up at the top of
the copy of what you really get a sense
of what lay beyond on that once
you got into the p. Dot. Saul,
I over here with its temple, uh,
and with its various shops. Uh,
you were in another world,
the commercial world also interesting is
the fact that although they're open to
the sky today in antiquity,
there was a covered call,
an aid as you can see here that would
have covered, uh, those shops. Uh,
and you would have had to go in
between the columns and back along the
passageway in order to check
out what the options were.
The city of Ostia, uh, like
all Roman cities that we've
talked about, Rome, Pompeii,
Herculaneum,
so on all obviously had a,
a selection of bath establishment.
Osteo was no exception.
There are a number of bows preserved
from the Roman city of Osteo,
uh, this being one of them,
the so called bads of Neptune,
the dates to 139,
a d the boughs of Neptune,
so called because of a spectacular mosaic
black and white mosaic of Neptune on
the, on the floor. I'll
show it to you in a moment,
but go into it in more detail
a bit later in the lecture.
If we look at the plan of the
bads of Neptune in Australia.
I wondered if any of you can tell me
whether this is a plan that corresponds to
the earlier bath buildings at palm pay,
the Stop and Basil, the foreign bas,
or conforms more closely to the imperial
bath type that we saw in Rome from the
time of Titus, let's say the boughs
of Titus and Trajan. Any thoughts?
Brooke's new grimaced but maybe I'll ask
you, do you have a pick on you earlier,
the earlier one? Absolutely.
And why, why do you say that?
Because,
um,
the series of bathrooms are coming here.
Excellent. Excellent.
That's exactly right.
We see the Palestra on one side
with the natal CTO or the PC.
Now that was usually usually accompanied
it over here. And then on other side,
all aligned in a row. Uh, the
typical bath, the bathing block, uh,
including the Apo d Terry
on the, uh, the caldarium,
the tip of Dory,
the tip of diarrhea in the call Dorian
and the frigate Dari and mold of the
frigging Dharm is not a round alcove
structure at all. So in that sense,
perhaps influenced by some
of what came in between, uh,
those early bands at palm pay
and the imperial Baz in Rome.
But [inaudible] and of
course also a note here,
the shops that line the front of it,
which is also characteristic of this dobby
and baths and the foreign bas at palm
pay. Uh, so they could
have chosen the other,
but obviously felt that this was much
more appropriate, uh, to this, uh,
commercial town to use the smaller,
more intimate bath type, uh, here. Uh,
then the imperial bas that
had been developed in Rome
from, uh, the first century,
a date on a just a glimpse of the black
and white mosaic that gives this bath.
It's name of the bads of Neptune.
You see Neptune here. Uh,
but you can also see the way in
which every room in the bath, uh,
which was made out of concrete,
faced with brick.
As you can also tell from this view,
uh,
every room was covered with
these black and white mosaics.
Ostia is the land of the
black and white mosaic.
A return to that in a moment.
Perhaps most importantly,
anything that I show you today are
the apartment houses of osteopath.
And it's to those that
I'd like now to turn, uh,
what you're looking at on the screen is
a model of what one of these apartment
houses would have looked like. This one
is the so called Insula, I, N S U l,
a Ciraphorus, the insula
of [inaudible]. Uh,
and we're looking at it in a model that
is in that Museum of casts that I've
referred to a number of times
this semester at a place
at a part of Rome called
Ar, e, u r, a that, uh, fashion,
that area that was built up in the
fascist period by miscellany in the 1930s.
It's, it, this model
is in that museum, uh,
and it gives us as good an idea as
anything I could show you of what one of
these apartment houses looked like in
its hay day in the time of Hadrian.
The word Insula, I should mention,
uh, it can be used in two ways.
And insula either refers to an apartment,
a multistory apartment house,
or it refers to a block of houses.
In a city like Ostia,
it's used for whatever reason,
it was used interchangeably to refer to
either block or to an individual house.
Uh, so pay attention to that when you
read about an insula or ensue lie.
Again, this one dates to the
second century had the, uh,
the, uh, insula of Syrup is, and it,
it basically was like a modern condominium
and often more than one of these
Insulite of where next w were
clearly next to one another,
but more than one sometimes
shared a common bath.
So they would sometimes build a
bathing bill, a bath building, uh,
that would be used by those who
lived in those two apartment houses.
Now, what's characteristic of this,
and especially as we think about it,
think about it in relationship to early
Domus architecture that we saw at palm
pay,
those single family dwellings is the
need in this teaming commercial city,
uh,
to accommodate a very large,
a population and a small amount of space.
Uh,
people on the whole who could not
afford single family dwellings, uh,
who needed to be housed in these apartment
buildings. They build up vertically.
Uh, and as you can see, they go
up to as many as five stories.
And we see that the insula of Syrup is,
was indeed a five storied structure.
It is made out of concrete.
It is faced with brick.
I and what is particularly interesting
about the brick facing here,
and this is going to be
our first example of this,
that Australia is the fact that some
point the Romans realize that brick was
really attractive in its own right.
Uh,
and that didn't need to
be stuck out over anymore.
If you think back to the dome is our area,
even in the Dome is our area.
The building was made out of the palace,
was made out of concrete,
faced with brick,
but the facade was gilded.
And inside you'll remember fabulous
was commissioned to cover the entire,
uh, stock, the entire interior of the
structure with stucco and then paint it.
So you would have had no sense,
uh,
when you were standing in the palace
of Nero and Nero's day that it,
that it was a brick face,
concrete structure. Uh, but
somewhere along the way,
and it comes to the fore. And the
second century Aidy, they realize, hey,
this brick is actually pretty
attractive in its own right. Uh,
it has texture. We can vary the
color. We can use a reddish brick.
We can use a slightly yellowish brick.
We can add some stucco to make some
decorative effects. This looks awesome.
Uh, and we think, uh, well, you
know, we, we, uh, some, some, uh, uh,
innovative architects got the idea in
innovative designers to let's leave it,
let's not stuck with it over. Let's
let, let it speak for itself. Uh,
and that was a very wise decision
because as you'll see today,
these are the buildings that we
have remaining from Osteo that were
unadulterated brick exteriors without
stucco are absolutely magnificent.
Uh, and, and they, and
they became the art.
The designer's became real experts at
rendering it in an extraordinary way.
I think you can get a sense of that
even in this model. So exposed,
exposed brick work here.
Uh,
you see these arches a made
of bricks that are, uh,
kind of wedge shaped and, and, um,
look like the sort of thing we saw
earlier in stone. Those wedge shape, uh,
sections of stone that we saw. For
example, in the Fillery, Novi a gate.
We see that sort of thing here.
It may have been used just
as it was in the Pantheon.
You'll remember how they use
them during the building,
a process to keep the concrete
from settling before it dried.
Uh,
but they realized afterwards that these
could be positioned in a way that made
them very attractive in their own right.
Ultimately,
we can also see that
they have added moldings,
usually with Stucco added
moldings, uh, that have,
that make the building more attractive.
Sometimes even little pediments as you
can see over some of the windows over
here.
So they come up with strategies to make
this brick look even more attractive
than it was on its own note. Also,
the shops in the first story. Uh,
some of these are shops,
some of these are actually staircases
that lead you to the upper most stories.
And once again,
uh,
it's clear that the Romans have become
so adept at using it and using concrete
that they are able to open up these walls.
The,
the openings are larger than they had been
even before. Uh, and so they're there.
They become very good at, at, at, at,
at, at, at d materializing the wall,
uh, in a way that, um, becomes
increasingly sophisticated over time.
The most famous house at Ostia is in a
sense mine because it's called the Casa
de Deana, the house of Diana,
uh, at, uh, [inaudible] and, uh,
we see a view of it
here as it looks today.
It was a multistory apartment building,
a multistory insula.
Only two of those stories are preserved.
Now I'll show you a restored view of what
the original looked like momentarily.
Uh, but we see it here as it
looks today, concrete, uh,
faced with brick exposed brick,
brick and joy in its own right,
very large openings that lead into their
either entrance ways into the structure,
uh, or uh, or,
or lead to stare Wa two
staircases or open up onto shops.
We can see here in actuality the same sort
of thing we saw in the model from AOR.
And that is the use,
not only have exposed brick but also
have moldings that are added either in
brick sometimes or also sometimes
in Stucco of the Nice uh,
overhangs that they have created above
the second story windows up there.
We also see a lot of Italian
schoolchildren osteon po on Pompei also,
but particularly osteon because of its
proximity to Rome and all the schools
that they have in the city of Rome.
Lots of kids always out in
groups and they always were,
they always seem to have t
shirts of the same color.
So you'll see one red school and one
yellow school. And when blue school,
it's a lot of fun and every one of them
has their set. It's so funny to me,
they have their cell phones and
they're all clicking, clicking,
clicking as they walk
through these buildings.
I'm not sure they're looking at anything,
but they're definitely clicking to
record the fact that they were at Osteo.
Perhaps that's for student papers,
I don't know.
But here I detail of the insula of Diana
looking through one of these entrance
ways into the rest of the structure.
And I bet yours and struck,
I am in looking at this,
that with regard to vista,
the interest in Panorama and vista,
it doesn't matter whether you're building
out of rubble or stone or opus and
carrot them or concrete or faced with
brick. Uh, there, there is that aesthetic,
that Roman aesthetic of,
of building things in such
a way that wherever you're
standing in that structure,
you're going to be looking from one part
of the building to another and you're
going to be struck by the wonderful
scenes that you see, uh, from, uh,
you know, within and from within that
building. And from that building.
Outside of that structure,
here's the restored view
of the insula of Diana, uh,
where you can see that originally
it was a four story structure.
It's a cutaway in an accident
metric view for story structure.
And this particular, uh, v,
this particular restored view is also
extremely helpful because it shows us that
these houses did not have, uh, the
peristyle courts or the Hortus, uh,
that we know from the Dome Missy
Tahlequah or the Hellenized Domus.
There was no space for that. Uh, in
this commercial [inaudible] city, uh,
there is no emphasis on the greenery
and the, um, the wonderful, uh,
fountains and, and statuary that we saw
in Palm Bay. And keep in mind of course,
it Pompei in Campania was
essentially a resort town,
a very different kind of feel then
Ostia this team in commercial center.
So what they replaced those with here
in order to get more light into the
structure is a kind of a lightwell. And
you see that light lightwell up here, uh,
where there are also windows on
multiple stories. And in fact,
I would imagine that those were the
choices, uh, apartments to have, uh,
because they would have been less noisy.
Uh,
then what you can imagine a apartment
along the street must have been a,
with all the activity going in
and out of the therma polio,
the other shops down below, um, and
the cart traffic and so on. So again,
I imagine the light, well apartment
would have been highly desirable.
Speaking of Thermo Polio,
we have them at Ostia as
we have them at palm pay.
Quite a number of them.
And I show you the best preserve which
happens to be in Diana's house. Uh,
and I show it to you here,
the Thermop Oleum of the Casa
de Deanna at a Ostia. Uh,
you can see that right
at the entrance way,
they have put a black and white mosaic.
You see inside just what we saw at,
uh,
just exactly the same thing
that we saw at palm pay,
one of these counters that
would've had recesses in it. Uh,
so you have to imagine just
the same as we saw there,
a kind of fast food emporium where
you would take a peek at what was, uh,
what looked good for the day.
Make your choice.
If you go inside the
Thermop Oleum of Diana, uh,
you see hanging on the wall,
a painting,
which it seems likely may have
served as a kind of shop sign.
It might've been a hung
outside the building to
advertise what you could get in
this particular Polian. And if we
look at what's depicted here, uh,
it's a still life of objects and we see
what seems to be a pomegranate on the
right hanging on a nail
on the wall in the center.
I don't know if you can
see it from where you sit,
but in the center of
block that supports a,
what looks like a drinking cup that
has little round things floating in it,
lentils or chickpeas or something
like that. And then at the far left,
there's a plate that also is on a block,
a plate that has a carrot
and some other vegetables.
So this may have been a vegetarian,
I guess this was a vegetarian
restaurant in palm pay, one of that,
one of the healthier places one
could go if one wanted a snack,
uh, in, in, in, in osteon. Excuse
me. Uh, for a very long, if, if,
if you go to Osteo,
by the way,
you really do want to set aside a day
to do that because the time you take the
half an hour ride out there, uh,
get there. There's a lot to see. Uh,
and it used to be, if you'd go there for
a day, which I've done many, many times,
uh,
there was absolutely nowhere to eat.
So you had to remember to bring your
band nowhere to get a bottle of water.
So you would have to remember to bring
your bottle of water and maybe a snack a,
but they have rectified that in most
in recent years. The last few years,
they finally put up the cafe
cafe therea daily Scobie,
which loosely translated as
the, the excavation cafe, uh,
the cafeteria of the excavations at Ostia.
And it's actually a wonderful place.
I have to say. It's very modern.
It has a wonderful deck with, uh,
tables and the ubiquitous Italian white
umbrella where one and the food is
actually, you know, for
a cafeteria. Ain't bad,
but Italian pasta is always hard to make
bad, so he's good. Uh, and then inside,
I thought you'd be amused to see when
they decided on the decor for the interior
of the cafeteria with its, with
its simple tables and chairs, uh,
they put brick on the wall and they
then hung up these wonderful versions,
uh, of the, uh, of the P. Dot.
Saul laid daily Corporates, Yoni,
a black and white mosaic. So again, very
attuned and Italians are really, I mean,
they do build Ferrari's after all.
They are very good, uh, at, uh,
at design and aesthetic and pay a
great deal of attention to that and
consequently always make one surroundings.
Pleasant warehouses.
This was up,
this was a commercial port.
We've talked about the fact that in
commercial ports, one needs warehouses.
We talked, we, it, we began the
semester with a warehouse. In fact,
the Porticos Amelia, uh, in Rome,
along the banks of the Tiber.
And I remind you of that here.
Here's the Tiber,
a model of the Tiber with the porticos.
Amelia,
you'll remember that was
made out of concrete.
It was one of the earliest examples of
concrete construction in the Republican
Rome. Uh, a series of barrel vaults
linked to one another on three tiers,
as you'll recall with axial and lateral,
a spatial relations inside that structure,
uh,
Po osteon needed its own warehouses as
well. It had them in the republic already.
Uh, but it began to add to
them in the second century a d.
And it's fascinating to see what happens
when you build a warehouse out of
concrete.
Faced with brick,
you get an extraordinary structure that
looks very much like an insula. I mean,
if I had put this up and said, what is
this? And you said it's an Insula, uh,
you would,
you would be sort of be on
the mark because it looks
exactly like an insula. Uh,
but it is a warehouse and this is
the most famous warehouse in Ostia,
this so called Auria because
the word Auria, h o, r, r, e a,
his warehouse in Latin,
the Orencia epic Athena,
which you have on your monument list,
which dates to one 45 to 150.
And this is the entrance to
the Ra at the got the, uh,
it is again made out of concrete
faced with brick exposed, brick work,
brick work enjoyed in its own right
for its own aesthetic here. Uh,
we can see that, that it is like the, um,
like the apartment houses in
that it is multistory, uh,
with the large entrance ways or entrance
ways into the structure down below.
And then the smaller windows up above,
they have monumental ISED the entrance,
the main entrance to the structure by
giving it a columns supporting a pediment
very grand in fact. And we haven't, we,
it's interesting to see that even with
this brick face concrete architecture,
the Romans have not lost their interest
in Helen Ising works of art and using
touches of ancient Greece to
monumental lies and to make more,
more, um, you know, more,
more cultured in a sense, uh,
the entrance way into this structure.
So we see these columns engaged columns
supporting a pediment above capitals on
those columns. As you can see
here, all of this done in concrete,
faced with brick.
And you can see here,
this is an outstanding example of the
way in which they have used brick,
uh, to their advantage. They have
recognized that you can vary the color,
you can have a reddish brick, you
can have a yellow, which brick.
So here they've used red brick to face
the column shaft and then a yellow brick
to,
for the capital.
So there's a distinction between
the shaft and the capital.
And they have even used the
most expensive material,
a marble for the inscription plaque where
they identify this building as the Ra,
epic God, Brianna, uh, and
then the pediment above.
And you can see if you look at the
pediment decoration and if you look at the
volume of the capitals,
you will see they have used a small
amount of stucco to enable them to ha,
to create, uh, the vault, the
spirals of the volumes, for example.
And some of the more delicate decorative
work in the pediment above another
subtlety,
a very another nice subtlety.
It just shows you the amount of effort
and time and money that went into this
commission. Also this very nice pilaster
that is placed right next to the column,
which makes a wonderful,
a wonderful transition from the column,
the roundness of the column to
the squareness of the Pilaster,
to the shape of the doorway,
the aesthetics,
a very much on the mind of this
particular designer as well as the list is
again, this idea of looking through
one space, seeing another opening,
and wondering where that opening is going.
All of that very,
very carefully designed by the architect.
Here's another view head on
of this elaborate doorway
leading into the Ra epic,
the Yana announcing with the inscription,
uh,
exactly where you are and what this
building was used for in antiquity.
A detail of the pediment, uh,
where we can see the inscription.
We can also see the capital's the use of
Stucco work here on the very elaborate,
uh, work that they have done to
decorate the pediment above. Uh,
just a few more details of the columns
where you can see even better, uh,
this capital and the way in
which they have used brick.
They have used brick for the,
even for the, uh, campus leaves.
You can see that there are a campus
leaves here. This is actually an example,
one of the few we've seen of the composite
capital with the canvas leaves of the
Corinthian and the volumes of the ionic.
We saw it on the arch of Titus and Rome.
Uh, but here we see that they've used
brick and then only at the upper,
most part with the leaf has to curve over
a do they add the stucco so tremendous.
And this is just a warehouse and yet a
tremendous amount of effort has gone into
making it an extraordinarily
beautiful building.
And it shows again that they
are absolutely going over
the top in terms of their,
uh,
of being a Namor of what they can do with
brick facing that they are now able to
expose once they can expose it,
they're much more willing
to put the effort into it to
make it really attractive.
And if you go into the courtyard of
the Ra, epic, Athena, and by the way,
behind within these areas here
we have a annual or vaulting.
You can see these niches
that have been placed here.
I mean they don't really need these
niches in this courtyard of this warehouse
of what did they use these niches for?
Well,
perhaps they put a little statuettes
of, of, of God's, uh, that the, the,
those who worked here favored and
protected their, their daily, uh, their,
their daily toil, uh, here in
the [inaudible] got the Ana.
But look at the attention that they have
paid to these niches that have no other
purpose than to be attractive and possibly
again to hold these statuettes. Uh,
but you can see here again with this
combination of Stucco work for the
pilasters and the capitals and brick work,
brick work creating these interestingly
shaped lozenges and triangles, uh,
to create,
uh,
shows an interest again in geometric form
and the contrast of one geometric form
to another justice we saw in
black and white mosaic, uh,
capitalized on by these designers.
Now,
I don't want to leave you
with the impression that
because brick is now exposed
at four and enjoyed in its own right,
uh,
that there are no walls that were
stuck out and painted in Ostia.
That would be a mis misconception
because there are still painted walls in
Australia on the insides
of some of these buildings.
They still opted to stucco
over the wall and to paint in.
And I want to show you
just one glorious example.
The insula of the painted vaults and
which dates to one 50 to 200 is one that
has one of our best preserved ceilings,
walls and ceilings
anywhere in a Roman house.
You can see how well preserved it is here.
And it is what we call the
spoked wheel effect, uh,
because what the ceiling decoration
does look like a spoked wheel. Uh,
we can also see this division.
In fact, as you look at it, I,
I think you'll be as struck as I am by
the fact that as we look at this boat
spoked wheel,
we really get the sense that we're looking
at one of Hadrian's pumpkin domes and
paint because you can see, uh, the
segmented dome effect here, uh,
and, and also the octagonal ice
in a sense, the octagonal effect.
That one also gets from this structure
as well as the effect of the ribs.
Of a groin vault, uh, as
you can see, well here,
but it's a painted version of a pumpkin
dome and it's not surprising to see that
Hadrian's, uh, pumpkin
domes took off in this way.
I also just want to mention to you that
while there is a fair amount of post
what we call postpone pay and painting,
Roman painting after a d 79,
almost all of it is,
uh,
an exploitation of the fourth style of
Roman painting as we know it from palm
pay.
There's actually not as much invention
as one would expect it after 79 in Roman
painting.
I want to show you very briefly
the insula of the muses,
the insula of the muses in Ostia,
which dates to around 81 30.
Uh, because this is one of the few, uh,
single family dwellings that we see
in the second century in Ostia. Uh,
you can see if you look at
the plan that it is a range,
not around an atrium but around
a Paris style court here,
although there aren't a columns,
there are these, uh, these, uh,
peers as you can see also in plan.
But just as we saw in the
late Roman house, the late,
how's the late first century Aidy
houses in Herculaneum from between the,
the, the, uh, earthquake and
the eruption of Vesuvius, uh,
the try Klinean has become the
most important room in the house.
You enter into it here. Uh, you have
a vestibule, you have this court,
and then you'll have on access
the try Clinique of the house.
But what makes this particular house
most distinctive is the fact that every
single,
every single floor is covered with mosaic.
So as I said to you before,
uh,
the black and white mosaic reign
supreme in the city of Osteon,
it's clear that everyone
who could afford it,
a decorated there every room
of their house with mosaic.
And although this doesn't come
from this particular house, has,
comes from the house of
Apple layups in osteous,
not on your monument
list down to remember it,
but I just wanted to show it to you,
uh,
because it's a marvelous
example of what can be done.
I wish it were a little more in focus,
but it's a marvelous example
of what could be done.
And was done using black and white mosaic
in Ostia only black and white test to
ride with a Medusa head in the center.
And then if you,
this is one of these examples,
uh,
illusionistic examples that as
you look at it and focus on it,
it's hard to tell exactly what's,
you know, what's in the foreground,
what's in the background.
It's got that [inaudible] op art effect
that those of you who know our op art of
the 1960s. And I, and I show
you an example of it, a, uh,
a painting from the blaze
series by the AAP artists,
Bridget Riley of the 1960s.
I've,
I've mentioned so many times in the course
of this semester that there isn't the
anything that the Romans didn't do, uh,
before anybody else. And this is, uh,
an op art is an example of that.
So we do see op art in Ostia, uh,
and um,
we see it obviously also much later in,
in more contemporary painting,
another bath structure in Ostia.
This one,
the bads of the seven wise men or
the seven sages dates to a d one 30.
I show it to you only to show you this
one circular room and not because it's a
bad building, but rather because it
has a wonderful mosaic on the floor.
I get a circular structure with
a circular mosaic once again,
done in black and white.
And if you look at this,
you can see that what we
have represented here,
I'll show you a detail in a moment,
is a flowering a can't.
This plant that has
intertwined within its leaves,
hunters and the hunted hunted animals
and they're hunters in combat as you can
see here.
Uh,
and here's the detail where you can see
once again done entirely in black and
white mosaic, the hunters, the animals,
very carefully depicted interspersed
among these, uh, these, uh,
flowering a canvas plants.
Very effectively done.
This is another view of the
bads of Neptune in Ostia,
which we looked at
before dates to 139 a d.
And this is a good view because it shows
you not only they, uh, uh, brick face,
concrete construction of these
structures, but also, uh,
the mosaics themselves.
Uh,
and how every single room of this bath
was covered with black and white mosaic.
The PSD raise the stalks. The finest
mosaic in the complex is this one,
and it's the one from which the bath
gets its name, the bads of Neptune.
Because we see Neptune himself
in the center of the scene.
It's not surprising that the,
uh,
that the god of the sea was chosen as an
appropriate subject for a bath building.
We see him here with his trident. That's
how we know it's him being, uh, being, uh,
carried along by four horses.
He's holding the reins of those horses.
His mantle is billowing up behind him.
One expects to see a cherry at here.
One thinks of this is Neptune in a cherry,
but it's not Neptune in a chariot. Uh,
you can see that these horses,
by the way, aren't fully horses,
but are the front part is a horse
and the rest is a sea creature.
And you can see that the
legs of a of Neptune,
our interests are interwoven, uh, with
the, with the tail of the sea creature.
He's in fact using the tales of
those sea creatures, almost like,
um, uh, you know, I'll miss
like skates or, uh, as he,
as he makes his way along
this or waterskiis I guess
is a better way of putting
it waterskiis as he makes his way from
right to left across the white background.
Uh, one of the interesting things about
this mosaic is you see the tension, uh,
in the, in the minds and, and, and,
uh, you know, and work of, of this,
of this artist, uh, in,
in, out in one hand,
making these very abstract black
shapes against a white background,
but at the same time paying a lot of
attention to the actual musculature,
to what the chest of the God, uh, uh,
beside and would have looked like. As you
look at [inaudible], there's, you know,
very pronounced musculature that's
carefully done here by the artists.
Here are our friends.
The dolphins frolicking a dolphins with
cupid's on their back, uh, some fairly,
uh,
other floating figures,
a female figure on the back of another
sea creature. All of this going on,
on the floor of the Bas of Neptune.
But what's particularly interesting,
I think is the same sort of thing
that we saw on the [inaudible] daily
corporates Yoni.
And that is that the artist has designed
this in such a way that it doesn't
matter which part of the room you're
standing in, wherever you are standing,
you can look onto the floor from where
you were standing and see at least some
of the figures head on,
whether you're standing here,
whether you're standing here, whether
you're standing up there or to the right.
You are always seeing some, not all, but
some of the figures head on. So again,
this is not, this is
done with great care, uh,
and orchestrated to fit the space in
which it was located here at detail of the
mosaic that we just looked at showing
Neptune and his horses and sea creatures.
The most important development
that happens at Ostia, uh,
with regard to residential architecture
later in its history is we do begin to
see the reemergence of the Domus
already in the second century.
And then even more so in the
third and fourth centuries. A d.
And I want to show you
quickly two examples of that
because they tell us a good
deal about late residential architecture
in Australia and also by association in
Rome.
This is the Domus of tuna on an Aria and
acts and a metric view of that house.
It dates to the late second century Aidy
but was remodeled significantly in the
fourth century, A. Dot.
D and I think we really need to think of
it as more a fourth century house then
as a, um, as a second century
house. And by the way,
pump Osteo was still thriving
in the third century by the 400.
By the year 480, it was abandoned,
but in the third century,
still a thriving and early fourth
century is still a thriving city. Uh,
we see this house here. It's a, an
accident metric view from Ward Perkins.
The most important features besides the
fact that it's a single story dwelling,
single family dwelling, is the fact that
it has an open court here with a pool,
that it has a, the [inaudible] idiom as
the most important room of the house.
So that continues on in
residential architecture,
but there's a particular taste for
apses in these late Roman buildings.
You can see that this one has an apps
not so unlike the apps that we saw in
demolitions palatine palace
on the Palatine Hill.
It is finally starting to
catch on among others. Uh,
we see that you go into
that, uh, that, uh,
that room through a and three arches on
columns a and this idea of supporting a
triple arch on columns is also a very
popular motif in domestic architecture in
later antiquity.
And look also at the fact that on the
left hand side of the track Klinean there
is a fountain. So the incorporation
of a fountain, a fountain,
a pool court here,
uh,
a fountain there and Apps try Clint Iom
and then views through triple a triple
arch is supported by columns,
all characteristic features of
late Roman domestic architecture.
This a view obviously through the columns
supporting that triple arch toward the
fountain on the left and toward the
apps in the center of the structure.
Uh, and you can see the remains of marble
revetment real marble revetment. Uh,
that was used both on the floor for
the pavement and also on the walls.
The other house I want to show you briefly
is the dullness of cupid and psyche.
The more famous of the,
to this dates without any question
to late antiquity to around a d 300,
uh, the house of cupid and psyche.
We see at first and plan a,
and you can see it's very simple
and entranceway here, a long Carter,
a series of cubic ula on either on one
side of that card or there may have been
a second story on a small part of the
house. You can see the stairway there.
As you walk along the card, you
eventually end up in the very large try.
Klinean so again,
from the time of the house and the mosaic
Atrium and Herculaneum to hear the try
Klinean,
uh,
gaining in importance as you walk along
that Carter and you look through a
series of columns supporting arches as
we'll see customary of buildings of this
time. And then look at this wall,
which is scallops, uh, for a fountain.
So another one of these fountain courts
that seems to be popular during this
period. Here's a view into
the room with the lovers,
the famous statue of cupid and psyche.
The young Cuban debate,
little young cupid's cupid and
psyche are embracing one another.
That's from that statute
that the house gets its name,
one of the best preserved marble
reverted rooms in the history. And the,
and the history of Roman
architecture is this room here,
the probably the TriClare diem
in the house of cupid and psyche.
You can see that even marble from the
walls is preserved as well as on the
pavement and on the steps and on the
side of the base of the walls as well.
Brick face, concrete construction
faced with real marble.
What makes this particular house,
uh,
especially appealing besides that
wonderful statue is the fact that although
there's the usual touches of Maroon and
green that we tend to see in many of
these Roman pavements.
Uh,
most of the color is a pastel and it
makes it look particularly attractive.
Uh, and it goes particularly nicely
with the red and yellow of the brick
construction. And I show you a detail
here, uh, of that marble revetment,
which gives you as good an idea as
anything I have shown you this semester of
what the original Hellenistic
palaces of the Kings,
the palaces of Nero and Domitian would
have looked like in their heyday and a
detail of the statue of cupid and psyche
and the room in which that found itself,
uh, it can still be
seen. They are today, uh,
and the marble revetment once again,
done in pastel colors of the floor
and of the walls, uh, giving us again,
an excellent sense, not only a fourth
century domestic architecture decor,
but also what so many of the buildings
that are no longer preserved, well,
who's revetment is no longer as
well preserved as one would wish.
What they would've looked like in
antiquity, a view through the Carter,
through the columns,
in this case,
gray granite columns that probably
would have supported an arcade a,
but then without question,
the fountain on the side of the wall,
that is scallop, uh, both
down here on the wall itself.
And then the columns
there do support arches.
So this whole concept of
columns supporting arches,
very much a part of late
Roman Haus design, uh,
in very few minutes that remain.
I just want to say a few words about,
uh,
we've talked about the life of this port
city I want to talk about since I said
that lecture was about life and death.
I want to just end with saying a few
words about the tombs in which the people
who lived here were buried.
Uh,
people all up and down the social
pyramid lived in this commercial center.
The simplest tombs,
and by the way I mentioned to you already
that there are tombs both outside the
city of palm pay on the major roads and
then a little bit further away at this
place called Easel,
a soccer or the sacred island where one
can see particularly WellPreserved tombs
from those who lived in Ostia of
the second century. Those who the,
the working poor,
we're buried in very simple tombs of two.
The upper part of clay am
for is just the upper part.
They were broken and then the upper part
was stuck with stuck into the ground.
The remains of the person
we're placed below the ground.
And then the spout could be used
to pour wine libations into, uh,
the other simple type was tiles that were
part of the body was placed below and
then tiles were ranged around
it looking almost like a, uh,
a kind of a house,
uh,
that helped to protect this idea of
the houses of the living in the houses,
the dead that were meant
to protect the body.
But most of the tombs are
what we call the house type.
We looked at the house type on the
VOP and the age of Augustus in Rome,
a tomb that resembles a house from the
front with a doorway and a couple of
windows,
and then an inscription plaque and
note the use of the travertine jams and
lintel around it just as we saw
on the markets of Trajan in Rome.
But if you look at these in this
very good view from the side,
you will see that almost all of
these are barrel vaulted tombs,
which is characteristic of second
century to market texture at Ostia.
Add easily Socra these barrel vaulted
structures with facades that make them
look like houses.
Here's a detail of one of them.
One of these house tombs with again
the travertine jams down below with the
touch of a pediment up above and
they haven't lost their interest in
Hellenization to a certain extent.
Windows here slipped windows here and
inscription along inscription plaque that
tells us who was buried there.
And then very often in these wonderful
tombs for this commercial center,
these panels that are done in terracotta
that tell us something about the
profession of those who are buried here.
Here's probably a shipper.
I was buried here, someone who made his
money in the import and export business.
And over here you can maybe barely make
out a representation of a mill just as
those that we would have saw.
I saw on palm payer,
we saw on the tomb of the baker,
you Rissa keys, a mill with a uh,
a worker and a mule that is helping
to rotate the mill of the bakery.
So perhaps a baker also from
this particular family. I've,
I've super imposed a couple
of other terracotta plaques,
making them a little larger here to
show you that these two belong to uh,
people who made their
profession by sharpening knives,
knife sharpeners and they not only
sharpen knives and you can see them both
doing this in this scene,
but they also sold them.
And I love the way in this still life.
They've a raid every possible knife
that you can sharpen here or buy a from
these individuals. And what do you think
the profession's where of these two?
This one clearly has shopped
someone selling things in a shop.
It looks like vegetables once again,
asparagus and maybe Broccoli or some
such over there. But what about this one?
What was the profession of
this one? Midwife. Midwife.
And I love this because here we
have this woman about to give birth.
She's got another woman I holding her
and giving her support and hear the
midwife instead of looking at what
she's doing, she's reaching in,
but she's not. She's, she's,
instead of looking at what she's
supposed to be concentrating on,
she's looking out at the spectator just
to make sure that we don't forget her
features.
Uh,
for posterity on this tomb
relief from her tomb in Ostia,
uh,
we saw columbaria these underground
columbaria with these niches where they
placed the cremated remains of
the deceased and had inscriptions.
We see the same sort of thing in the
interiors of tombs that Ostia but they are
on, they are above ground rather
than subterranean at Ostia.
And we also see,
and basically the last point I want
to make today is we also see in the
interiors of these tombs that osteon
not only those niches for the cremated
remains,
but it's in the second century ID,
the time of Hadrian on that information,
burial becomes the norm, uh,
largely on, under the influence of
the spread of Christianity. The idea,
the of the stole soul
needs to ascend to heaven.
And so you have to maintain
the bodily remains.
And so we begin to see in these
interiors what we call Arca Soliah, arc,
Arco, AARC, O, s, O, l, I, a Arco Soliah,
which are these much larger
niches where bodies are placed,
bodies are buried,
and then they are covered over with
a marble slab that might have the
inscription naming the deceased
or, uh, a figural scene.
And just in closing,
to show you one last tomb that
we're going to look at next time,
the tomb of the [inaudible] II
and the Vatican cemetery in Rome.
I to show you that these concrete brick
faced build as tombs with windows and
with very elaborate interiors also
begin to be put up in Rome in the second
century ID.
We'll look at those.
We'll look at the title of next
time's lecture is bigger, is better.
We're really going to culminate our
move toward larger and more grandiose
buildings then.
And then on Thursday we will finally move
out to the provinces by studying, uh,
Roman architecture in Roman North Africa.
Thank you.